[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] them
[Music]
happy st patrick's day
thanks for joining us here on the johnny
michaels podcast youtube twitter twitch
live
[Music]
soon eastern 11th central
every single weekday
we have a special guest for you today
the mooch is with us today that's right
anthony scaramucci is with us today on
the tony michaels podcast
we will be rounding up that interview
soon soon soon as we go through the
announcements
we will play the uh interview with
anthony he goes through he goes to a
couple different topics we ask him about
the book deals that are coming out of
the trump administration you know
anthony has written a couple books about
the a couple books and one of them about
trump and so i wanted to ask him about
all the book deals and how he felt about
bill barr stephanie grissom some of
these others
um that are going through
uh this this cycle it seems that they
withheld
that they withheld
information
from the trump administration
so that way they could profit
from a book
is what it appears to be so we asked
anthony about that situation we also we
also asked him about uh
cryptocurrency
nfts challenge anthony a little bit on
that and then of course
anthony gives us
his opinion
on donald trump and if trump runs again
uh anthony says what he will do
if trump runs again
so stay tuned today you're gonna want to
stay tuned for the entire two hours
we are going to play anthony the
interview with anthony scaramucci coming
up very soon in the first hour
in the first hour there's a lot of
announcements to get to today
a lot of news going on we've seen
yesterday
that president zielinski addressed the
united states congress
most of the people clapped some of them
didn't clap no matter what daniel dale
or anyone else says marjorie taylor
green
did not [ __ ] clap daniel dale that's
all [ __ ] you look at the [ __ ]
video there's no [ __ ] way that anyone
could get confused about what she was
doing
no one
no one's confused by this not one person
is confused about marjorie taylor green
whether she was clapping or not this
should i shouldn't i i surely shouldn't
i really shouldn't clap for democracy i
really shouldn't clap for democracy i
hate democracy she wasn't clapping
she might not even been listening
really honestly i mean i guess it's
possible that she wasn't even listening
at that point
she tuned off
when president zielinski had called joe
biden the leader of the world and was
speaking about democracy in a way that
most people would
like for people and politicians in this
country
that democracy elected
most most
most would clap for that or pay
attention
marjorie taylor green ah don't think so
don't think so
good morning everyone everyone's in the
chat here robin's in the chat debbie is
in the chat lisa good morning
good morning good morning kathy's here
kathy is here we have several kathy's
nancy's here
jay is here
everyone is here this morning good
morning good morning good morning stay
tuned today you're gonna want you're not
gonna want to change the dial as it were
on the radio i feel like we are kind of
a radio show what do you guys think
we're like a live radio show that's the
feel of it with the commercials and
the lead in
how we go through all the news of the
day the trendy trends and the tweety
tweets
i think i think that's
that's kind of the feeling that we have
right
uh another kathy's here
[Laughter]
oh
boy we've got we've got everyone here
everybody's here today
so
we also have news um of arnold
schwarzenegger
uh
speaking out against russia and
encouraging uh russia to
no to war in other words
uh we have that we can go through today
uh nestle uh willie wilson um we have
hunter biden hunter biden's trending
again hunter binds laptop
i don't know maybe hunter biden's laptop
is uh
making a statement today
about how they're disappointed about the
how they're sanctioned
[Laughter]
sanctioned
from russia
i mean makes sense you would i mean
russia would sanction hunter biden's
laptop and hillary clinton's emails
that is the thing that would happen
now we have cuomo in the news apparently
he's suing maybe uh and then we have a
bunch of seditionists traitors
gqp putin traders in the news we got mo
brooks josh hawley and marjory taylor
green are all trending
and we know one reason why marjorie
taylor green's trending
she's a traitor mo brooks
the funny part about mo brooks
trending is uh he
donald trump has turned his back
on mo brooks this is the guy that wore a
[ __ ] bull approved vest for him that
day i mean mo brooks expected to take a
bullet for donald trump on january 6
during the insurrection
he thought he might and i mean i don't
know
there's got to be a reason why you would
[ __ ] wear a bull approved vest to a
to a
a joint session of congress where you
vote to certify a vote that's already
been certified by the seats seems a
little weird
a little [ __ ] weird but you know mo
brooks
is a [ __ ] weirdo but apparently he is
too weird for donald trump
too [ __ ] weird even for the cheeto
dust mobster cheated us mobster has
endorsed his primary
challenger in the republican primary
this is
so yeah yeah he's he's
he's [ __ ] trump sycophants right
uh jeff sessions you remember that [ __ ]
he became the uh the attorney general
the first attorney general in the trump
administration
now he had to recuse himself from
several cases
and then and then he he got on trump
[ __ ] list because he wouldn't he
wouldn't just start prosecuting and
jailing all trump's enemies
it really pissed trump off and he
wouldn't protect trump you know he
wouldn't he wouldn't make sure that mike
flynn that [ __ ] trader stayed in his
administration
you know
it is what it is so jeff sessions
is no longer a politician
louie gohmert goes to run
goes to run in texas
and [ __ ] flops gives up his
congressional seat to run
[Music]
whoops that went over like a wet fart
and a white thong
and now mo brooks
don't say i mean we really shouldn't say
that
trump doesn't do everything all bad i
mean he i mean
really honestly
but these boneheads doing what they're
doing by giving up their seats and
trying to run for other seats and then
he endorses the their primary challenger
i mean
you know it really is starting to
bleed off some of these dumb [ __ ] jeff
sessions louie gohmert mo brooks
i mean hell maybe maybe we should do
this for all of them
i don't know i don't know
there's several other trumpers in the
news look at the dead josh hawley is
trending i'm not sure why joshua is
training actually
i know why josh holly is trending josh
halley's trending because he's a dumb
[ __ ] nazi probably most like most
likely that's that's why he's probably
saying pro putin pro nazi [ __ ]
they all are
they all are this morning yesterday
they'll continue they love putin
they love an autocrat
fascists do
why wouldn't fascists love autocrats
and fascists also love to praise people
who praise autocrats i have a clip for
you
on that today as well
so
a few things few things before we start
um i don't know if you guys saw this
yesterday rachel bitkoffer was on our
show
um
and we didn't get a chance let me let me
share my screen here really quick
there we go okay uh rachel was on the
show yesterday
and i played a clip uh but there's been
another clip
that's played i know we're not to the
treaty treats and attorney trends yet
but um we are we are we played a clip
yesterday rachel is going to be
debating charlie kirk tonight
you believe this going to be baiting
debating charlie kirk tonight now
whether you watch it or not you know
whatever i'm sure i'm sure there'll be
clips of her of her totally destroying
him very soon i'm sure of it
but here here's here's one of the clips
that charlie kirk's team put together
for rachel uh for the debate tonight
let's let's listen in here
[Music]
what does race have to do with anything
why does that matter to you none of that
stuff's taught in our schools right now
because of crt no it's not have you ever
taught any hit any kids because i don't
know if i can believe your bullet points
so like it means
the article for you i mean but you know
unconscious yes
none of it's true i drive a pickup truck
and watch football so i'm definitely not
a good leftist right i love that
oh
rachel bitcoffer is a pickup truck
libtard
[Laughter]
and charlie kirk loves that he loves it
then liberals drive pickup trucks that's
really cool you mean you mean that's a
thing you can do liberals can buy pickup
trucks
charlie kirk is such a dumb [ __ ]
i want to show you um
uh look look here look at that
look at the shirt she's wearing
let's get a good image of it here
fascism sucks
fascism sucks
what a great shirt that is
what a great shirt that is
we really appreciate uh
rachel um going and challenging charlie
kirk
and to it to the old time battle
they're down in uh you know
moronville
i think it's in arizona's where his
headquarters turning porch usa is but
she wears the fascism sucks shirt hold
on see the fascism sucks fascism sucks
by the way if you want to get a fascism
suck shirt
go to
hats.d tonymichaels.com use the promo
code podcast get 10 off again go to
hats.dtonymichaels.com or go to
thetonymichaels.com the links in the bio
just go to the there's the fascism sucks
i get it up at the very top
just go to the tonymichaels.com or go to
hats.thetonymichaels.com use the promo
code
podcast
to get 10 off fascism sucks shirts
how freaking exciting is this
how exciting is this here i'll put the
link in the
in the chat here
there you go
there's the website there's the link use
the promo code podcast
and get 10 off
your fascism suck shirts so thank you
rachel for
wearing the shirt on the show
uh against charlie kirk let's play this
uh one more time listen uh we'll we'll
skip the intro debate night like it's
actually gonna be a debate
i'm sure
rachel rolls him open rolls him up and
smokes him one more time what does race
have to do with anything why does that
matter to you none of that stuff's
taught in our schools right now
because of crt no it's not have you ever
taught any any kids because i don't know
if i can believe your bullet points so
like it means
the article for you i mean but you know
unconscious yes
none of it's true i drive a pickup truck
and watch football so i'm definitely not
a good leftist right i love that
i love that i love that charlie kirk
what a goofball what a goober
so you can catch that tonight go to
rachel's page
um
she's got the the uh the the info over
there it looks like it's uh six o'clock
second six o'clock eastern i believe
if you can bear through charlie's
[ __ ] but i'm sure i'm sure they'll
be clips
i'm sure there'll be clips i'm telling
you there's going to be clips there's
going to be clips of rachel bitkoffer
absolutely destroying charlie kirk so be
prepared maybe over the next you know
over the weekend or something for
charlie kirk to probably be trending
because a pickup truck libtard owned his
ass
i think that's i think that's what's
gonna happen so shout out to rachel
thank you rachel
um for wearing the shirt again if you
guys want to get
and we'll keep we'll keep showing you
this the the fascism sucks shirts
t-shirts that rachel was wearing
it's hats dot d tonymichaels.com or just
go to thetonymichaels.com the fascism
sucks link there is is there use the
promo code
podcast
and get 10 off
your order
and your entire order for the store
whether you want to get the just the
shirt or you want to get a [ __ ] hat
or whatever go over there check it out
helps out the podcast thank you rachel
for wearing the fascism
sucks shirt
on charlie kirk's little debate night
show so check that out if you can or
wait for the clips
i'm sure they're coming
uh let's see here let's go we're 17
minutes into the first hour we're gonna
play anthony scaramucci uh uh interview
at the bottom of the hour but i do want
to go through a couple clips here
uh of the trendy trends and the tweety
tweets i don't know are we officially in
the [ __ ] list i don't think we're
officially in the [ __ ] list i think
we'll do the [ __ ] list after but i do
want to run through some clips here um
on my timeline
of the trendy trends and the tweety
tweets i think this is very very very
important here
let's get down here to um
where we want to be uh here we go here's
ron's get the marjorie taylor green clip
that's not exactly the one i want to
show we'll come back to that
possibly uh when we get to the trendy
trends uh free britney brittany grinder
there's a the video of her in court in
moscow we'll get to that today
uh hopefully in the trinity trends and
the tweety tweets you guys see that
uh midas touch is in a little bit of a
a tussle this morning with uh daniel
dale you guys know that we're
we we are we are a proud
distribution partner in association with
midas touch here on the tony michaels
podcast
and uh we've had our little scuffles
with daniel dale as you know in the past
uh gabe
davis always is always
prodding to daniel dale and those fact
checkers
uh in general but daniel dale is has
fact-checked gabe a couple times on his
uh his trump mar-a-lago statements and
we we've tried to get daniel dale on the
show and he won't come on we want to
challenge daniel dale
to a fact check battle i guess you would
call it but that this morning uh mind is
touching daniel they are at it because
daniel dale says that what marjorie
taylor green definitely was clapping
forget about forget about her being a
fascist and basically saying that putin
putin is the good guy forget about that
news forget about the news when she
followed up with a fascist type
statement blaming biden calling biden
the bad guy and putin the good guy
forget about that
forget to totally forget about that
what you need to know is marjorie taylor
green kinda kinda made it look like seem
as if she thought about clapping she
thought about it
kinda i mean clapping because everyone
else was
she didn't wanna clap for democracy
get the [ __ ] out of here i wanted
applause
barely rubbing her [ __ ] hands
together
marjorie taylor green she wouldn't she
wouldn't [ __ ] clap for democracy you
kidding me
she barely stood up she stood up got her
phone she's like i need to text putin
i think that's what ben my zella said
she was texting putin so that that
little that little battle is going on
but let me show you something here
uh this is this is very important in
this uh this internet fight yesterday
um
this is what i said looks like this
tweet may have kicked off a twitter
battle
this is the uh this is the tweet that i
sent out
earlier in response to
um
midas touch
marjorie tate green reported them for
misinformation misinformation she did
clap
she clapped by god
she kind of i mean you know thought
about here's here's the clip you guys
decide look at this here you go here's
here's the part that they're calling
applause right
i mean you can see the entire room is
actually applauding everyone's standing
up even even the pro-putin republicans
are standing up applauding and
pretending they love democracy right
they're i mean you know that gqp is
really good they've done this for
decades and decades they're really good
at pretending they love democracy here
so they stand up and pretend that they
love democracy and they're actually
giving an applause
but watch what margery tate look at
where she's got her hands right now in
this freeze frame
they're behind her
she's looking around ah looking around
uh maybe i'll put yeah put my hands
together maybe
ah no no no no
probably probably not nope [ __ ] that not
gonna clap not gonna clap for democracy
not gonna clap i mean you see the entire
room again yep you're [ __ ] mitch
mcconnell
republicans
they're all standing up yeah
yeah we love democracy
i mean we pretend we pretend to love
democracy
we don't want our constituents to
believe that we don't love democracy she
doesn't she doesn't hide it
um so i said here's what i said
yesterday my response to that was that
they were fact-checking or is it
misinformation that she actually clapped
or applauded which she didn't
i said we could get
gabe sanchez to page daniel dale for a
second opinion
i mean daniel dale's
always has his opinion on on gabe's
statements maybe we'd get daniel dale
and apparently
it it happened because
gabe gabe said here happy to jump on a
call with daniel dale
to investigate further
oh [ __ ]
god damn we lo we like pissing off
danger damn and daniel if you're out
there i'd love to have you on the
podcast man
absolutely we would love to have you on
and listen to your really shitty hot
take about what applause is and what
applause isn't
love to have you on here
we would we would scratch out plenty of
time
to listen to what you think clapping is
and what clapping isn't and you will
fact check your ass how's that sound
daniel come on come on man we'll have
you on
we won't be mean i promise
i mean we'll just you know state facts
yeah you like the facts don't you
do
okay let's go back here
yeah so i started a twitter battle
apparently i'm sorry i'm sorry i didn't
mean to okay
i i got um
i got a video i want to show here
um
and this is the vladimir putin video i
definitely want to show that one today
we got that one coming up we're 23
minutes into the hour we're gonna play
this anthony scaramucci interview here
at the bottom of the hour um i want to
play this right here though first um i
think this video is very important
to some of the conversation that
happened yesterday with the president of
the united states and the president of
ukraine
as he gave his address to congress and
then what actually happened after that
when the biden administration gave one
billion with a b
billion dollars in aid
to ukraine as if we're not doing
anything
as if we're not doing anything now now
marjorie taylor green that fascist at
pro putin fascists is really [ __ ]
butthurt because we the united states
government gave a billion dollars to aid
ukraine yesterday because it's gonna
help tear down the leaders she loves
putin
and she loves putin she loves him oh she
loves him i think she loves him more
than donald trump maybe loves him i
don't know but let's let's listen this
is an interview with
uh with james long
of abc news and this woman here in this
frame
um she is a russian mother of a soldier
and uh they're speaking here
and you'll see the police kind of
enter the chat so so pay attention here
i'll try to i'll try to read as we go
along for the people with just listening
to the audio it says this woman is the
mother of a russian soldier
she says
he moved to a hot spot after being told
he was going on drills
she went 10 days without talking to her
thank god he's alive she says only 10
people are left from his regiment
i think this is very significant you
know this is where this is where a lot
of the truth is starting to uh leak
through in russia where um it's
real-time stuff where their their
children who are fighting in the russian
army against ukrainians have been duped
into going and killing ukrainians
and committing war crimes against
ukraine
and they're calling back to their
parents saying hey this is [ __ ] weird
over here
this
is weird
here you go
now she's she's kind of quieting down
and and changing her posture here as
james starts to question her
um and the reason why you'll see is that
the police are starting to pay attention
here watch
they say could you show a photograph of
your son
it's getting quiet now
the chanting stops
she's getting nervous
we were with the lady and we were in
moscow more and more people had come to
protest the war even though there is a
massive security presence and the lady
has come to talk with us because of her
son has been uh constricted she says to
the russian army to fight you in ukraine
she now also worried because the police
was watching us mothers of conscripts
are now also
potentially
going to be arrested for opposing this
war
so uh james here reporting that these
people who are out there protesting this
war you heard the chants stop because
the police showed up
because they were chanting no to war you
guys seen the uh the video of the
journalists coming on the rt broadcast
with a sign on the broadcast said no to
war no to war no to war and then uh and
they're freaking the [ __ ] out over there
and the reason why is because
the truth the truth shall set you free
uh democracy will set you free too
not fascism not a
authoritarianism not totalitarianism
not this this putin-style fascism that
they have in russia
russia is not communist dummies
putin is not a communist he's an
authoritarian and he's using fascism
to hold on to his power in russia
that is the whole [ __ ] point
the whole [ __ ] point
uh he says it's a very tense situation
she's trying to show a photograph
they're looking through their phone for
a photograph of her son who has been
duped into going to ukraine
[Music]
to fight and kill
innocent ukrainians
as the aggressor he's been duped to be
the aggressor
she's showing a picture of her son here
of course she's very worried because the
police are watching her you can hear the
police radios in the
background and here they are the police
are right behind her
she's run away as you would imagine are
you still rolling again
uh james james uh be careful out there
this is james longman if you guys aren't
following james he is posting a lot of
videos from moscow he's in moscow with
abc news um he's doing the best he can i
hope james stays safe over there and he
continues
continues to spread the truth
um so please give james some love go
watch his videos go follow him on
twitter
it's james a a longman
see if we can put it in the
in the chat here for you
there we go
go go follow james on twitter if you
want to see
reports
from moscow any in some of the reports
end up on abc news but some of the
reports end up just on his twitter page
just on his social media
so go go follow james
um he's reporting over there from moscow
james if you if you do see this stay
safe my friend and keep reporting
you are you are doing democracy a
service
um well there's also a herschel walker
video out
campaign video yeah we're gonna watch
that
we're gonna watch that there's some
stewart road news
it looks like let's see what else did i
have on that oh my god did you guys see
this
out of plano texas this guy here
holy [ __ ]
holy moly this guy this [ __ ] guy
crazy ass some [ __ ] it's uh we won't
play the whole thing
but we'll play part of it we'll
definitely play part of the plano psycho
i'm not sure what he's trying to get at
here it's it's very strange
it's very strange we'll play some of
that that was a viral video yesterday
let's see what else do we got when we
round up the tweety tweets and the
trendy trends
i think that's what we'll have today
pretty much on the tweet and then we'll
go through the sweetie tweets and the
journey trends we're almost to the
bottom of the first hour anthony
scaramucci coming up very very very soon
stay tuned for the anthony scaramucci
interview
stay tuned for the mooch
he goes through he goes through
cryptocurrency he tries to convince us
that nfts are a good thing
he does a decent job at it anthony's a
smart guy well read knows what he's
talking about
knows what he's talking about um
you know he was he was inside the trump
administration and one thing i wanted to
make sure to ask him when we were in
this interview is about the book deals
like bill barr and stephanie grisham all
these people leaving the trump
administration because trump to anthony
has written written a book himself on
trump
uh so we asked him about that
so
let's let's make sure let's make sure
we get that in so stay tuned don't go
anywhere right after this message
is the interview with the mooch anthony
scaramucci
be right back with anthony
[Music]
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50 a day
you can help us help those true
americans recover from biden's socialist
reign of terror these are those trump
supporters and this is that moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only 50 dollars a day
recurring and it means you'll get these
trump supporters the critical help they
so desperately need to survive under
this false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
catch tony's twitch stream the [ __ ] list
roundup at twitch.tv
slash the tony michaels
we're back to the king of brilliant this
is the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
i welcome back everyone from the break
we have
the
mooch with us the moon
we have the moot anthony thank you for
joining us here on the tony michaels
podcast um as you know we are the the
the [ __ ] fan fam so anything goes on
this show here you love the fact that we
both got the champ behind that that's it
that's it right there see that that's
that's right a lot about it tells you a
lot about us man that's right that's
right i i appreciate i appreciate brad
connect brad berkowitz connecting us and
and getting you on the show and shout
out to brad there
anthony we have several things we want
to ask you we don't have a lot of time
with you today but we have several
things we want to ask you number one um
we just seen a lot of people from the
trump administration which you were a
prior trump administration official
yourself um
we've seen a lot of them hold
information for books
now you wrote a book about your part in
the the trump world
how do you feel about some of these
people holding this information
do you think that's a disservice to the
country in disservice to
what their role was and what their oath
was to make sure the american citizens
knew some of this stuff because it seems
like some of this stuff
was really really really important stuff
that americans would want to make
decisions on their vote what's your view
of that so um you know listen we i think
this is a very big philosophical
discussion i would like to live in a
normative society where
people do the right thing and we live in
a world of ought like it ought to be a
certain way and it
should be a certain way but that's how
the society is you have to remember
donald trump was a formidable guy
he was the leader of the free world he
was the democratically elected president
of the united states most still the most
powerful country in the world
and so what happens is you get this fear
basis and this sort of membrane
around him
and i think it's sort of impossible to
pretend otherwise and
you know i made my mistakes there guys
i've always admitted that you mentioned
brad bergwood i had a couple of great
interviews with him right very tough
questions and what i tell people is you
never know what you're going to do until
you're in the situation unfortunately
right um and so
um no you're right that stuff should
have came out immediately i wish
the people around trump had spoken more
openly about it
when i started speaking openly about it
it was in 2019
people thought i was crazy they were
like oh my god you can't talk like that
he's going to get reelected right i know
this guy's got no chance of being
reelected and i explain why
but um
you know it's fear-based guys you know
and and i have i have sympathy for
people
who are in those positions and i would
say this to you
winston churchill had a great line he
was being really badly criticized by
somebody
churchill looked at him and said you
know the best among us the best
among us choose
not to judge human frailty
so harshly so let me repeat that because
i think it's important the best among us
choose not to judge human frailty so
harshly and i think
i think i've taken that tact in my life
i'm forgiving of those people
because we need more of those people you
know the worst thing that can happen to
somebody where they're in a cult like
trump's they start to speak the truth
and then they're roundly criticized and
what that does guys is it frees the next
person from coming over the chasm and
the next person behind them and so i
don't want to be one of those people
that overly criticizes these people i
want to welcome anybody
that has had the strength or the change
of heart
uh to go after that son of a [ __ ] are
you allowed to curse yeah you can say
whatever you want
i think anybody that's willing to go
after that son of a [ __ ] has a role on
my team
remember what churchill said if lucifer
was going after hitler he would be sure
to mention something nice about the
devil in the house of commons right you
know i mean you know sometimes you gotta
you gotta just team up with people
whether you like everything about them
or not yeah i would just i would just
hope that i think on to add to that is
like yeah it takes obviously a lot of
you know you could say courage or
bravery to speak up you know there is a
point of like uh you know how long is
too long right you've got stephanie
grisham and other people who come out a
year a year and a half two years after
and they're like i saw the like but in
order to know exactly what i saw you
have to buy my book and you're like but
then are you doing it out of the out of
the good of your heart or are you doing
it out of the yes the breed of money you
know so i think those are good questions
and anthony maybe you can answer this
because i've been raising this question
on my show you know we do it every
single weekday live we do a two hour
show every single day um
and
i've been raising the question since
bill barr and the stephanie grisham's
stories come out about their books is
that
how does the book contracts work i have
it in my mind that like there was these
there was these people in washington dc
with these publishers that were like as
these people are leaving the door
they're like hey we'll give you a book
deal don't say anything and you've
written books uh you know how the book
deals work so tell me am i wrong in that
assessment no that's how they work i
mean listen if you're
i'm gonna give you this book deal and if
you go out and start talking about the
juicy stuff that you're gonna put in
this book then it's not worth it to me
it's not creating the sensationalism
that i need to sell the book and so yeah
i mean you know that's uh
that's how it works of course it works
like that i mean it also it very much
seems like the okay just sit still don't
just just keep collecting don't do
anything because you know if you get up
and leave then it ruins the possibility
of that that juicy goss right listen i
mean he was crazy though i mean you know
let me let me tell you something i think
about how crazy he was
and the fact that he still has a
stronghold on 10 to 12 percent of the
population right well they say oh his
approval rates at 36 percent of the
republicans republicans are only 28 of
the registered votes you know so 10 or
12 percent of the population
primarily because of fox news and some
of these other conservative radio
outlets and so forth they buy into his
nonsense but
he is a buffoon
he has no ability to manage a process no
executive
management skills whatsoever he's a big
fat bully
uh and so he'll use those brutish
intimidating tactics to try to knock you
off your game and he can do that to
politicians because they're not used to
that you know politicians try to speak
with a civility to their language
because they don't want to be offensive
you know a politician walks into the
room like okay i'm going to make this
speech i got to make sure these two guys
at least are neutral on me before i
leave
you know and trump is a smash mouth
talker you know he's a he's like a shock
jock dj sort of candidate
and those politicians weren't ready for
him when he says lion ted cruz
and then he says ted cruz his wife is
ugly and his father like was involved in
the kennedy assassination i mean he
broke
he broke grandpa munster right take a
look at grandpa he broke grandpa months
to ted cruz right the guy gained 60
pounds since trump broke him he's become
a miserable stooped train wreck
and he sits there and he's like
you know at mar-a-lago with ted cruz i
mean it's unbelievable you know he's
like that wreath you ever watched game
of thrones i've only seen one episode i
never watched but i mean you look it up
i mean they had this one guy who just
got his ass kicked by the other guy you
know cruz is like the reek of the ball
you know yeah
well uh the the haircut and the beard
might prove it all as well not just the
weight gained and the trip to one time
but dude i mean he got he got destroyed
you know if he you know when he when he
went off
went after my wife on twitter
trump that is trump when trump went
after my wife hey are you kidding me
right well these people still work for
us guys don't forget about that right
this isn't even though trump loves putin
this isn't vlad putin's country okay
small country yeah right those people
work for us
they're supposed to be public servants
that means they're serving the people
we're their boss they're not our boss
they're living in our house
the people's house okay so yeah and we
still have the first amendment in our
country okay so you want to go off on my
wife
on the presidential twitter feed i'm
gonna kick your ass in okay since i
can't physically kick your ass i'm gonna
go on television and radio and podcasts
you know one of the things i did which
people did not really remember is i went
on local news
because i know the average american
watches local news you know right
you know
we perhaps watch cnn or msa nbc or fox
but you know the blue collar worker they
want to see what the weather's going to
be like you know they got to go outside
and work tomorrow
and they're going to be on a 6 p.m news
local 11 p.m news i was on those
stations right smashing him man right
well and he makes
if he runs again
i'll be out there again you know no
problem well you make a good point about
some of this putin puppet thing because
uh we've seen that here with the ukraine
conflict and actually
deutsche bank is in the news today where
they're not going to cut ties they say
it's um it's inconvenient or you know
they use some kind of excuse where
they're not going to cut ties with
russia and putin oligarchs it seems like
um and maybe you have some insight on
that but it really does it really is uh
something to see when you watch like you
said fox news and some of these other
outlets
being
putin's content creation for russian tv
basically what it is and then you have a
lot of the republicans in the republican
party really trying to run away from
this idea that they that they embrace
putin and embrace his murderous victoria
they suck man come on they suck the
country but you know they say about a
democracy the people get what they
deserve you know we're not paying close
enough attention you know and they suck
i mean you know first of all putin is a
murderous thug right putin's about to
get annihilated now because he
prosecuted the war improperly
and he they got crippling sanctions on
his country are going to bankrupt them
they've got 300 percent
inflation in russia
and but you know these guys are afraid
of him okay what is he going to do he's
going to serve you some polonium tea and
knock you out of the game i mean okay
let me tell you something you cannot if
you love freedom guys you cannot live in
faith in
in that fear basis right you love
freedom no fear you love freedom you got
to speak truth to power you got to tell
people what you really think and what
it's really all about and that's how you
shake
these mad men that's how you shake these
demagogues because they're just one
person you know what i hate about
what's going on right now you got a
couple of really bad actors
that are affecting and hurting lots and
lots of good people you know and it's
our indifference of their bad actions
right
you know when hitler needed to get his
ass kicked in 1938 but we appeased him
you know and now look i don't want to go
to war with vladimir putin over the
ukraine okay it's not in our national
interest to do that it isn't our
national interest
to fight him there and to reject him and
to send material and help those people
protect their own country but i don't
want to go to war any more than i wanted
to go to war with the nazis
when the nazis invaded russia you know
we sent this is the irony guys 80 years
ago we sent arms
in the len lease prop
project to vladimir putin
now we're sending arms to ukraine
to protect themselves from vladimir
putin and again i'm using vladimir putin
it could be joseph joseph stalin you
know when stalin was getting attacked by
hitler we helped him
you know and now we got to help somebody
who's getting attacked by russia you get
them well and i think i think you bring
up a good point because i think vladimir
putin's aim here is against democracy
it's not really against ukraine of
course um
that that was always his aim with with
uh supporting the trump presidency and
supporting him not just in 2016 election
but possibly the 2020. we see a lot of
uh uh well even this ottawa trucker
thing it seems like there's a lot of
russian ties there and some of these
other some of these other elections on
the world because vladimir putin knows
that democracy is his enemy yeah the
vaccines guys all that [ __ ] you know
they got maps
of canada
the uk united states
and they say okay here we're going to
drop a racial invective over here we're
going to put anti-vaxx propaganda out
over here we're going to say really woke
stuff to trigger red state voters and
over there we're going to say really
radical right wing stuff to trigger blue
state voters and they've got hundreds
and thousands of made-up personalities
and if you guys have an interest in
understanding this read
putin's people
by katherine belton
she wrote an extraordinary book
about the legion of scumbags that
surround vladimir putin who have made it
their life's work to divide break up
and destroy the west and
it's not about left or right as you just
pointed out
it's about the dissension it's about
creating havoc
and despoiling the democracy i want you
to believe that the election
was stolen if i can get you to believe
that right and that de legitimizes your
concept
of our democracy it's exactly you got
[ __ ] like trump
feeding right into it you know right he
has been he has he's he's orange for a
reason right got a lot of
dominant i mean he's a really bad guy
well take it from me whatever whatever
you [ __ ] think of me
i'm telling you did not one person that
worked for that son of a [ __ ] liked him
trusted him
thought he knew what he was doing
hundreds of thousands of lives
were destroyed by his decision making
during covet 21 million jobs were lost
on his watch
he is the modern-day herbert hoover
uh
he lost the house the senate and the
presidency so
anyway
well in i can't [ __ ] stand the guy
and
i can't wait if he decides to run again
and get my ass back out there to pounce
on him well we we can't wait to see you
i want to ask you
about nfts and and crypto because i know
i know you know a lot about it and you
got some at stake here i don't know much
about the crypto or nfts for that matter
i know gabe knows a lot more than me but
the word the word and and i want to
press back on on crypto and nfts and and
get you to defend it a bit the word scam
comes up a lot when you're talking about
crypto nfts a lot of people get worried
about it um even even the notion of
white nationalism white supremacy starts
to leak into this conversation about
crypto and nfts so tell us about uh
crypto and then gabe i'll let you kind
of uh give anthony the pressure well i
mean yo listen i mean
it's a new technology
cryptocurrencies are 12-ish years old
but they're really starting now to
really be adapted you know it was a
microcosm of adoption now the adoption
for something like bitcoin is 240
million wow so so that's a
in my opinion that's an escape velocity
number imagine we were on this podcast
eight or nine years ago
and we were talking about facebook
and i said fellas facebook has 240
million users
someday
facebook's gonna have three billion
users you'd be like whoa whoa that's not
gonna [ __ ] happen give me a [ __ ]
break but that's what happened and then
look at the stock price and look at what
happened you see what i mean and so
bitcoin to me
has got these technical properties that
we can use as a fully transparent
ledger
and a distributed spreadsheet if you
will or ledger between ourselves
and once you understand it that way and
then once you understand the concept of
money
you can see how bitcoin could get
adopted nft is a different story nfts
are effectively a smart contract
that are put on different
cryptocurrencies not bitcoin but
currencies that are known as layer ones
right what does that mean i got a layer
of software code
and i'm going to add a layer and that's
the smart contract so now i've got two
layers
and so if i have the original
photograph
of that knock down of sunny liston
that's behind you mm-hmm
original and i want to take a
3d
data snapshot of it
and then i want to put a little digital
fingerprint on it
and put it on top of ethereum
or solana these layer one currencies i
now have an nft
and i can trade that with somebody else
so it's a piece of digital art
or it's a piece of creative expression
now
somebody would then say well jesus
christ why the hell you need that it's
just
some frozen ones
on the internet but then i would say to
you well there's a uh
there's a piece of cardboard a little
bit bigger than this
uh it was printed in the mid-century the
mid 20th century it's got four color
process ink on it on one side is a
picture of mickey mantle
on the other side is his height and
weight and his
minor league
stats because it's his rookie card right
everything is selling for 5.2 million
dollars and so what you find is
if something is scarce
has some nostalgia or memorabilia value
to it people will pay something for it
and so
um you know but i mean what is that card
really worth it's the identity
associated with the court right but
within it with a digital
that piece of art all that is is oil
on canvas is that worth anything well
it's a very well-known artist it's
signed by muhammad ali probably can't
see it that well but you can see his
signature on the top mm-hmm okay and so
a result of which that's valuable right
so that's that the nfts
is a digital expression of that art
and is some of it hyped and some of it
going to be destroyed and go to zero
certainly just like any other art is
what you're right yeah i mean some of
the art is decorative and other art is
done by an amazing artist that's no
longer with us and it goes up in value
and so to me
it would be foolish to think that we
can't have a digital expression of art
um the same way we have a virtual
expression you know and and by the way
people spend time
on their screens they spend time
observing digitization
and data
you know some people are in the
metaverse some people are in gaming
people like myself perhaps i'm
logging into the net to search things or
answer my emails
and so you know we're we spent a lot of
time in the digital world
it would make sense that there would be
some expressionism
and some art in the digital world as
well and that's what you get with these
nfts for me i'm an artist and a designer
and so like you know i obviously want my
work appreciated but like you know if
you've got a physical piece of artwork
behind you that's an oil painting with a
signature from muhammad ali that's
obviously going to have you know value
because it's one of a kind right and i i
think on the nft side you know someone
could say yeah sure i want to print this
on top of
uh crypto to say you know this is this
is tied to this
tied to ethereum but
um
you know what's to say from all the
other people who have been uh
stolen artwork right uh fraudulent and
fakes are easier on the digital side
than it is on the actual physical side
i'm not the best on the technology i
think some people would say well whoa
they can do that but there's still this
noticeable digital image slash watermark
that makes it original but i'm not i'm
not the best on that but you know that's
like the double spend in bitcoin let's
say i own a bitcoin
and i try to send it to both of you at
the same time right right so it'd be
like me having a dollar in my bank
account and i want to pay for something
with it to you and i want to pay for
something with it to you and all of a
sudden now i'm uh
i'm double spending
you know the technology is there to
solve for and block that
but
you know i know that that's a worry and
i know that that's why there's so much
fear and uncertainty and doubt
in these new technologies
well and i think that that goes both
ways with the you know because that's
why the word why the word scam or people
start to doubt the crypto and the nft
because like you said they don't
understand it um which the way that you
explained the nft
uh i didn't i didn't even know that much
um where where they have the different
layers um and and so that kind of makes
more sense and i appreciate you uh
coming on and taking a little heat about
the crypto and nft i will there i do
have one last question is uh what's your
what is your take on the most recent uh
decision from the white house on
regulation of digital currency i took
that i took that favorably you know the
executive order more or less said hey
you may like crypto or you may dislike
crypto but you know what it's here to
stay right so we're going to fairly
regulate it right right we're not going
to over regulate it and try to kill it
i'm not going to under regulate it
whether it'll be susceptible to fraud
right and i thought that was positive
the more responded to that the more
morgan responded
to that yeah it certainly seemed that
people were
potentially worried that you know the
government was going to step in and do
something but this is more like hey you
know we've seen the scams and we've seen
the frauds i mean just even the crypto
couple that recently was uh
was a was arrested um you know i think
that's something else in your mind it's
like you know this is actually i mean so
so i mean that's another mis yeah
exactly that's another misnomer people
think that uh oh you can use crypto for
scamming the minute that couple tried to
spend the money bang they were arrested
you know and fbi director ray said
yesterday
they identified isolated and froze 4 500
accounts associated with the russians
were trying to move money in
cryptocurrency markets out of russia
so you know they they don't dislike it
they think that they can get their arms
around a lot of fraud with it right so
so do you think that the executive order
really does um if the aim is to
uh quote unquote legitimize it where it
really it makes it makes it easier for
normal average people to say hey maybe
maybe this is something because a lot of
people don't understand it right they're
like what do you mean it's it's a it's a
coin a digital coin right they don't
they don't really can't wrap their heads
around that
but but with the government regulating
it and maybe even the federal reserve
considering their own digital currency
uh you know in the executive order i
think it mentions that
does it do you think it gives that
legitimacy for normal people to say
maybe this is something that's not as
much of a scam or it's not something to
be scared of
so the short answer is not yet right
but i think your trajectory is good
right i think people i think and and
what i've told clients
is i would like
them
to get involved
before it's overly definitive in other
words i have made it i have opined i
have made a decision that i think that
the regulation is going to be benign and
generally friendly right there's a lot
of people that are offensive waiting for
more information right i'm telling my
clients get in now right if i'm right
it'll be a much higher price as a result
of that makes sense yeah no no i it
totally makes sense it doesn't make
sense and i know you i know you got to
run next time we've got a really good
trivia game to play with you give me one
truth before i blow it out okay yeah
yeah let's watch one trivia question one
trivia question okay all right all right
in the scaramucci universe the movie 500
days of summer would actually be titled
what a
42 scaramucci's of summer b 43
scaramucci's of summer
c 45 scaramucci's of summer or d46
scaramucci's of summer and i'm using the
basis of 11 days by the way yeah
what do you think anthony what's the
answer i'm doing the math of my ad you
got to give me one second
i would say
44 days right 42 43 45 46
okay i'm gonna say
45
scaramucci's that is correct okay ding
ding ding
see see that's good that so we have we
have more scarecrow i know it was
[ __ ] great though the goldie han's
daughter
can't remember her name but when i got
my ass fired from the white house
she put out a meme
how to lose a guy in 11 days oh you
remember that show right yeah
it was me and trump and the meme it was
so [ __ ] horrifying
it was so embarrassing you know what i
mean so so one more question one more
name but she was really sticking it to
me good you know what i mean well we'll
look it up and we'll we'll put it up on
this yeah it's [ __ ] great so so let
me ask you one more question before we
leave then
what is what is the actual official
time of a scary moochie is it 10 days or
is it 11 days everyone not only is it 11
days let me explain i got hired on the
21st got my ass fired on the 31st right
count the days it's 11.
when trump was bashing my skull on
twitter
he said he was here for 11 days so i
feel the president
of the united states
as much as i hate the [ __ ] guy's gun
was pointing out that i got i was there
for 11 days so for everyone wondering as
scaramucci
in in the time in the time frame is
officially
11 days
by the way it's that's good for you guys
because if i wish you a great scaramucci
of vacation yeah don't you want it to be
11 days versus 10. yeah absolutely
absolutely absolutely anthony thanks for
joining us i really appreciate it well
guys we'll we'll see you soon maybe
we'll play some more trivia and get you
some more scary questions
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
are you annoyed by masks infringing on
your rights do you wish you didn't have
to comply with biden's communist mask
mandate are you tired of wearing masks
that actually fit your face
well now you don't have to be
introducing the droop with our patented
droop technology every mask is uniquely
molded to not fit your face just send us
a selfie and we'll have one of our
drupists mold the mask for you elastic
free thanks to the droop i don't even
need to pull my mask on anymore it just
sags that way the drip lets you
customize from a selection of pre-worn
masks lipstick stains included make sure
to order your droop today drew be the
spread you want to see in the world
[ __ ] we're back to the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking with the mooch the
interview with the mooch
[Music]
so glad to have the mooch
on the tony michaels podcast
what a great guest
we hope to have him back to play more
more uh trivia gabe
it was a fantastic time that we had with
anthony even though we had a short
amount of time
yeah it was uh yeah definitely shorter
than we wanted i've got uh several more
scaramucci trivia questions
yes um yes like how like time brain
question because yeah yeah yeah like if
i were to say time frame it'd be it'd be
uh
uh let's see don't give too many away
because you mean right if i use the unit
of 11 i'd say it's it's less than half
of scaramucci worth of questions oh okay
good good good good yeah yeah so we got
so we got a few left yeah
who knows i might come up with some new
ones yeah well you know maybe maybe
maybe like we should play if anthony
would allow us we would play scaramucci
trivia where like we just play with
anybody not just anthony but yeah it
could be a whole thing
right right it could be i i think i
think anthony gave us some good insight
on that on that interview
one of the reasons why is because i
don't think he's ever been interviewed
on the book deals yet i don't think he's
given some of his insight on that um
which i think i know of because
when
right before we did the interview you
know we were discussing you know uh
stephanie grisham and then it just
you're talking about where she was on
the view and she was saying these things
that she had in her book she's like guys
it was bad right but buy my book and
you'll find out just how bad right
thanks thanks for letting us know when
it counted right yeah the formative
years of the pandemic you know
right right so the other the other thing
that i think is significant about the
the interview um if you go back and
re-watch it which it looks like we might
be able to post it somewhere to where
people can rewatch it this week weekend
is that
he talks about crypto and nft
and he almost convinced me he almost
convinced me that
he almost but but i think he fell a
little short um he makes good points
about art and what art is and and i know
you're a designer so elaborate a little
more because crypto is kind of a
different kind of animal than nft
they're both digital product right right
most virtual digital products right
they're not tangible yeah the the whole
idea behind nft is this like
non-fungible token right like you want
to
you want to assign a value to
a digital piece of art right and it
would uh
you you know it wouldn't you couldn't
stop anyone from going somewhere taking
a screenshot saving the image of you
know like there's the um
there's the there's i mean there's a ton
of artwork that's out there that's nft
worth
um but
yeah you
there's nothing to stop someone from
just like all of the internet before
that like people stealing memes or
reusing images or doctoring stuff like
you wouldn't be able to stop anyone on
the digital side from going to a site
looking to say oh look i'm on open c and
i see this image i want to right click
and i want to save it and then i want to
go somewhere else i want to sell my own
like
yeah it's not the original
but also it's like how would you know
any different just from the the face
value the
the um
the initial kind of look or glance at it
you wouldn't know a good example is i
think i think uh um
oh what's his name the singer the guy
that's really popular on social media he
bought a he bought an nft and he made it
his profile picture well
and i don't know
people are going to roast me because i
don't know i can't think of his name
right now but i want to say justin
timberlake but it's not justin it's uh
uh um
anyways the point is the point is when i
really stepped in the pile of [ __ ] there
yeah
i mean you gotta tell i don't know he's
from canada he's the he's the young kid
he's always been
that's it justin i knew see i knew
justin
holy [ __ ] they're gonna they're gonna
eat me alive now yeah i didn't even know
that i i couldn't wait for them
well you know what happens but justin
bieber i think bought a he bought one
right and he made his profile oh yeah
it's like a um it's a monkey right yeah
so the eight that's one of like the the
ape
uh series are one of the most well known
so if you're trying to copy an ape one
you probably wouldn't get away with it
because people right but but
but
the point is is that he made it his
profile picture right now it's it's more
than that to him but right everyone's
like oh nfts they just screenshot and
make make it their profile picture like
right it really isn't that hard and i
think i could do an image search on
google find all of these ones and just
make it my profile photo that's whatever
i know that twitter has a new nft
profile photo option which i'm like
so what does that mean does that mean
you can sell the the profile pic i don't
know i g here i'm going to be honest
with you i have no idea what it is
because i got this alert that was like
hey now we're supporting nfts with
profile photos like
and i was like nope not doing that not
obviously you you you completely it's
just like i got it i got you a little
notification yeah i got a notification
on twitter and i was like uh nope not
doing it i don't care like because again
you know like i you know that's
for the same reason that you could yeah
you get like this like fingerprint um
of for for an nft to say like oh this is
an original this is the one right
um
it's the same reason i put a like my
handle on the memes that i make that i
photoshop because my guy you know i i do
put a decent amount of effort into it
and i don't want it to you know not go
acknowledged and it is great when i see
it around the internet and people like
reusing it and using comments and
posting here and there that's awesome
however
that doesn't stop anyone from taking the
image right scrubbing out my handle
right and putting their own thing or
cropping it out and then boom you don't
you know you never
know who you never know who gabe sanchez
is right well and but but but
i think i think that's sort of the point
for like um
you know
common folk on social media right if you
want to call it that because i think
that's really that's really where this
lies is that
just like people um who are very wealthy
pay a lot of [ __ ] money for a
painting that hangs on a wall where most
people just go to like their local decor
store and they might pay for a painting
that's right you know 20 bucks 30 bucks
or whatever to hang on the wall it's
kind of the same operation right yeah
and i and i also want to say like as as
a designer and as an artist like you
know i said in the event i want my work
to be acknowledged and
yeah i you know if at some point it's
like hey i want my work to
to sell for this amount of money
that would be great however i think the
valuation of artwork is a completely
subjective and isolated thing that's
done away from other people but only
done by the rich to determine who
is a rightful
or worthy
artist and what is the worthy
uh value to go with it and on top of
that
also
art the art scene is a money laundering
operation i just want to put that out
there like the way that uh artwork right
valued
it's it's not done by the market it's
set by private people so let's say i
wanted to move around some money i could
theoretically do and it has been shown
before to do it through uh an art
gallery you know it it is a way to
transfer wealth or in case you're
talking dirty money like there is it it
is a way to transfer that which
again and i think the en and maybe the
digital world would be a little
different with the nft and the bitcoin
and crypto you know like anthony was
talking about
but it's all new to us
and i think us doubting nfts and crypto
is kind of like people in the in the 90s
like have you ever seen that that uh
that clip from uh good morning america
we're like what's an email what the
hell's an email yeah you know so yeah
yeah so i want to be very cautious here
to say that all crypto and all nfts are
are all [ __ ] and it's all horseshit
but i will say that because it is in its
infancy um it it won't look the same now
as it did as it won't it won't look the
same in the future as it does now there
will be something yeah there will be
something about and we see that in the
executive order that the administration
signed to try to basically say what the
[ __ ] is crypto why does it matter and
why does it matter to the treasury right
so we'll we'll see that uh i do i do
want to get to some other news i know
you got a little bit of time to stick
with us today
um i want to go to the tweety treats and
the trendy trends but i don't want to
waste a lot of time with the music as if
i want to get right to it there is this
video going around right now of arnold
schwarzenegger it has about uh i think
on this one has 3.4 million views uh let
me bring it up here um he is uh i
haven't watched this yet uh have you
have you watched this clip yet
i started watching right before i uh
jumped on it's pretty long but
everyone's uh it seems like everyone's
talking about it so i at least want to
give it a little bit
it is a very long video so let's watch a
little bit of this at least if not all
of it
hello everybody
and thank you for sharing your time with
me
i'm sending this message to various
different channels to reach my dear
russian friends
and the russian soldiers serving in
ukraine
i'm speaking to you today because there
are things that are going on in the
world that have been kept from you
terrible things that you should know
about
but before i talk about the harsh
realities let me just tell you about the
russian who became my hero
in 1961 when i was 14 years old a very
good friend of mine invited me to come
to vienna and to watch the world
weightlifting championships
i was in the audience when yuri
pedrovich flossof won the world
championship title becoming the first
human being to lift 200 kilograms over
his head
somehow a friend of mine got me
backstage
all of a sudden there was a 14 year old
boy standing in front of the strongest
man in the world
i couldn't believe it
he reached out to shake my hand
i mean i still had a boy's hand he had
this powerful man's hand that swallowed
mine but he was kind
and he smiled at me
i would never forget the day
never
i went home in the buddhist photo above
my bed to inspire me when i started
lifting weights
my father told me
to take down that picture
and to find a german non-austrian hero
he got really angry and we argued back
and forth
he didn't like russians because of his
experience in the second world war
you see he was injured at leningrad but
the nazi army that he was part of did
vicious harm to the great city and to
its brave people
but i did not take the photograph down
no because it didn't matter to me what
flag yuri flowers have carried
my connections to russia didn't stop
there by the way oh it actually deepened
and i traveled there with bodybuilding
and for my movies and met all my russian
fans
and then one of those trips i remember i
met yuri vlasiv once again it was in
moscow
during the filming of red heath which
was the first american movie allowed to
film in red square
now he and i spent the whole day
together he was so thoughtful so kind
and so smart and of course
very giving he gave me this beautiful
blue coffee cup
and ever since then i've been drinking
my coffee out of every morning
now the reason why i'm telling you all
these things is that ever since i was 14
years old i've had nothing but
affections and respect for the people of
russia the strength in the heart of the
russian people have always inspired me
that is why
i hope that you will let me tell you the
truth about the war in ukraine and what
is happening there
no one likes to hear something critic of
the government i understand that but
as a long time friend of the russian
people i hope that you will hear what i
have to say
it may remind you that i speak with the
same heartfelt concern as i spoke to the
american people when there was an
attempted insurrection on january 6 last
year when a wild crowd was storming the
us capital trying to overthrow our
government
you see there are moments like this
that are so wrong and then we have to
speak up this is exactly the same with
your government i know that your
government has told you that this is a
war to denazify ukraine
to nazify ukraine this is not true
ukraine is a country with a jewish
president a jewish president i might add
whose father's three brothers were all
murdered by the nazis
you see
ukraine did not start this war
neither did nationalists or nazis
those in power in the kremlin started
this war
this is not the russian people's war
no
as a matter of fact let me tell you what
you should know is that 141 nations at
the u.n voted that russia was the
aggressor
and called for it to remove its troops
immediately
only four countries in the entire world
voted with russia
that is a fact
see the world has turned against russia
because of its actions in ukraine
whole city blocks have been flattened by
russian artillery and bombs including a
children's hospital in a modernity
hospital
three million ukrainian refugees
mainly women children and elderly fled
their country and many more trying to
seek to get out
it is a humanitarian crisis
because of its brutality russia is now
isolated from the society of nations
you're also not being told the truth
about the consequences of this war on
russia itself
i regret to tell you
that thousands of russian soldiers that
have been killed
they have been caught between ukrainians
fighting for their homeland
and the russian leadership fighting for
conquest
massive amounts of russian equipment
have been destroyed or abandoned
the destruction that russian bombs are
raining down upon innocent civilians has
so outraged the world that the strongest
global economic sanctions ever taken
have been imposed on your country
those who don't deserve it on both sides
of the war will suffer
the russian government has lied not only
to the citizens
but to its soldiers
some of the soldiers were told they were
going to fight nazis
some were told that the ukrainian people
would greet them like heroes and some
were told that they were simply going on
exercise they didn't even know that they
were going into war
and some were told that they were there
to protect ethnic russians in ukraine
none of this is true
the fact is that russian soldiers have
faced fierce resistance from the
ukrainians who want to protect their
families in their country
when they see babies being pulled out of
ruins
i think that i'm watching a documentary
about the horrors of the second world
war not the news of the day
now let me tell you when my father
arrived in leningrad
he was all pumped up on the lives of his
government
when he left leningrad he was broken
physically and mentally
he lived the rest of his life in pain
pain from a broken back pain from the
shrapnel that always reminded him of
this terrible years and pain from the
guilt that he felt
the russian soldiers listening to this
broadcast
you already know much of the truth that
they've been speaking
you've seen it with your own eyes
i don't want you to be broken like my
father
this is not the war to defend russia
that your grandfather so your great
grandfather's fought this is an illegal
war
your lives
your limps
your futures are being sacrificed for a
senseless war condemned by the entire
world
as to those in power in the gremlin let
me just ask you
why would you sacrifice this young man
for your own ambitions
the soldiers who are listening to this
remember that 11 million russians have
family connections to ukraine
so every bullet you shoot you shoot a
brother or a sister every bomb or every
shell that falls is falling not on an
enemy
but on a school
or a hospital
or a home
i know that the russian people are not
aware of such things are happening so i
urge the russian people and the russian
soldiers in ukraine
to understand the propaganda and this
information that you're being told
i ask you to help me spread the truth
let your fellow russians know
the human catastrophe that is happening
in ukraine
and to president putin i say
you started this war
you are leading this war
you can stop this war
now
let me close with a message
to all of the russians who have been
protesting on the streets against the
invasion of ukraine
the world has seen your bravery
we know that you have suffered the
consequences of your courage
you have been arrested you have been
jailed and you have been beaten
you are my new heroes
you have the strength of yuri petrovich
phlosov
you have the true heart
of russia
my dear russian friends
may god bless you all
so quite the uh statement um
from uh arnold schwarzenegger and i do
want to say that um arnold with all his
flaws um i do appreciate him giving this
statement because i know his voice can
be heard in some of these places as he
said
there's one thing that arnold
schwarzenegger is very good at as you
notice he's very good at storytelling um
that's why he went from being a
bodybuilder to a world
world-renowned
known famous movie stars because of his
storytelling ability
um and i mean i remember the i remember
the january 6 video that he made last
year which was very like heartfelt to
talk about what his
experience was like in austria and how
you know the parallels between that
germany and right about his father he
brought his father up here right exactly
like you know if we if we you know uh
you know
have a blind eye to this then we're
going to let this happen if we don't
take it seriously then it'll get worse
like you know he's literally the
company's like listen i've got a
personal anecdote to tell you about [ __ ]
that happened uh when i was a kid
in my history and i don't want to see
that happen here
because this is
the same early signs that we saw
well and i think i think the uh
the fact of the matter is is that he's
trying to make sure that anyone who can
and will hear him who will listen to
arnold schwarzenegger which i think is
the most important factor here right
regardless of some of his past you know
honor schwarzenegger like most of us is
not perfect and he's very imperfect to
be frank especially in some of his
personal relationships um
demonstrably imperfect yeah but but
still there are people who will hear him
and i think the most important thing is
that if we can get truth and that
because that's the most important part
of this is that democracy stand right
like the entire world isn't standing
with ukraine because you know somehow
ukraine is the
the pinnacle of democracy it's not right
but it is
trying to be democratic like as
unsuccessful as they are sometimes and
as corrupt as it is sometimes democracy
is really [ __ ] hard we talk about it
here all the time it's really [ __ ]
hard yeah [ __ ] hard that even us the
shining city on the hill elected donald
trump one of the most [ __ ]
politicians that we've ever seen in our
country and we elected him and put up
with him for four [ __ ] years not only
that the party who elected him who is
now gonna pay the price for him i
believe that's what's gonna happen here
they're gonna pay the price for a very
long time for for making him the
president and the nominee and possibly
the nominee the next time
is that
they
they still still can't figure out how to
unwind themselves from him right and i
believe that if arnold schwarzenegger
can
find a way to get
regular russian people are ukrainian
whoever
to
figure out a way to untwine themselves
from a murderous dictator because
it is [ __ ] gross to watch politicians
in this country like this [ __ ]
buffoon
here
marjorie taylor green
to
not only not only uh uh
put in with putin but jesus christ this
is this is her response
to
the the address
of not just not just um
the president of ukraine salinski but
also
joe biden this is really [ __ ] gross
really she's even looks like she's even
changed her uh
her
campaign logo to match the same style of
trump
well um so that's a good point um let's
see if we can um
zoom in on that this is a save america
stop communism
uh
we weep when we see images of men save
america stop communism
right what's funny about this this is
all kinds of turned around legit like
literally the right
right now is saying we're not putin
sympathizers he's a communist and then
they support him and then they have
stuff like this which she literally who
vladimir putin is not really a communist
or a fact he's an authoritarian he's
just using fascism right now to advance
his author authoritarian cause right um
also no one no one asked her to speak by
the way this is completely on her own
where she's like congressman marjorie
taylor green addresses the nation the
war on ukraine like this is not some
official [ __ ] this is her going off
rogue just like she went off rogue for
her america first response to the state
of the union it's this [ __ ] and
whenever it's broadcasted on oan or
whatever but at
the
the heart of it no one said hey marge
you should make a response video she
said
i should make a response video right no
one was like you know what we need we
need more response videos from marger
taylor green no one said that except her
own
her own mind well you know a lot of
people are upset about this video which
it is appalling no totally especially
this clip but here's the thing is i
always say this
do not look away and we have to give
marjorie taylor green is the republican
party yeah if you're not aware
she has no [ __ ] committees she is a
do nothing in congress an absolute
[ __ ] do nothing she can't do anything
for her [ __ ] constituency in georgia
the only reason why she still exists at
all is because the republicans love her
because she's a fundraiser that's it and
she fundraises off fascist [ __ ] like
this
that's why that's why she is the
republican party if you don't believe me
go back to 2016 and see how they
stripped away stripped away
off the republican platform anti-russian
uh uh parts of their platform
she says it she paired it's it here yep
in this statement
if you don't believe that marjorie
taylor green is the republican party
hook line sinker go ask mitt romney mitt
romney
but he won't he won't say he won't say
she shouldn't be a republican he won't
say it he said she's dumb she's stupid
you remember this a couple weeks ago
yeah i mean you know mitt romney comes
in whenever it helps himself right i
mean like well obviously you can make
that argument to any politician but at
the same time like mitt romney only
comes in to act like the savior
when
uh he feels it's right and for the most
point i'm trying to but yeah but the
point i'm trying to make here is not
about mitt romney it's about marjorie
taylor greene she
is her matt gatz joe kent who's running
in washington's third which i think we
might be able to get to part of that
today uh we're 26 minutes into the
second hour so i don't know we'll get to
that even because we got a lot of [ __ ]
to go through here but let's let's
listen to the the hoof foot here and
let's see what she
the the [ __ ] has to say and don't look
the [ __ ] away i'm tired of people saying
oh i'm sick of hearing from her and i
don't want to hear from her she is the
republican party
their message is her message her message
is their message this is who they are
voting for we need to let these people
know that they are voting for the
marjorie taylor green gqp
we weep when we see images of men women
and children wounded or killed
we regret any human suffering and we
mourn any loss of human life
but we cannot but we must not allow our
compassion to blind us to reason and
common sense
because this won't be like any
entanglement america has ever entered
into before
a potential war with russia is not
comparable to iraq or afghanistan
this is an eight-year-long smoldering
conflict in which peace agreements have
been routinely violated by both sides
it concerns a country in which joe biden
nancy pelosi and mitt romney have direct
financial interest
a country which government only exists
because of the obama state department
helped to overthrow the previous regime
the ugly truth is that america is in no
shape to throw herself into another
foreign conflict but that's the exact
opposite of what is happening like
literally it is not that's not what's
happening at all not even [ __ ] close
if she would pay to she would pay
attention for more than a half a [ __ ]
second instead of uh uh playing with her
cell phone during the address
that president zielinski was giving she
would know that that's not what was
going on and then like she should have
just stopped like that first 20 seconds
where she was like we don't want the
loss of life children you know
she could have just left it right she's
like full stop cool that's my statement
and uh like we hope that the situation
improves
through the aid and assistance that
we've given ukraine
um to prevent
further death and murder right and then
she's like above
but but all that doesn't matter because
she talks about romney and everyone else
you know she runs through a little list
of people who are financially deep
stateless tied to uh a you know
pro-ukraine and meanwhile it's like well
i'd love to see the financials on
whether money's coming from
russian
interests you know right uh so it's it's
ridiculous i don't know if anyone's
watching the brittany uh uh is a grinder
story from russia she's being held in
russia here is here's her rocky on a
court today now she's in she's an
american
uh uh wnba player i believe um and she
has been
it says wmba center brittany griner
appeared in a moscow court today where
she is reportedly pled guilty
not guilty excuse me to drug charges the
court extended her detention uh another
two months uh this is just punishment
from putin is all this is um it's
intentional obviously um that's what the
the jest of it is um so go go
read up on the story of brittany griner
at the american basketball player that's
being held in the
in moscow did you did you see this video
yet i'm gonna play this again is this
the one is this this is the one from
this morning
um did you know rachel bitkoffer is a
pickup truck libtard did you know that
what
she is yeah she is she's a pickup truck
libertarian
watch watch this video real quick
[Music]
none of that stuff's taught in our
schools right now look at this guy
look at this guy
what the hell is this you know people
talk about how small his face is on that
plate head of his it is the truth isn't
it that's not like just
photoshopped it's real because this is a
clip he put together he put this clip
together
like maybe find him more flattering
right look at the shirt she's got on oh
you you see that game yeah yeah fascism
sucks shirts
go to hats.d tonymichaels.com use the
promo code podcast to get 10 off fascism
sucks
t-shirts or go to the tonymichaels.com
the the link in the bio uh she was
sporting a fascism suction shirt or
taught any kid any kids because i don't
know if i can believe
your bullet points so like it means i'll
print out the article for you i mean
he'll print it out he'll print it out
who prints anything do you print [ __ ]
anymore i mean other than your like your
hat things yeah yeah i do print uh uh i
actually had to buy a new printer uh
today it should be arriving today
because
what you what
because my printer broke i had to buy a
new printer
but the reason i have a printer is
because when i print out uh my scripts
when i'm doing a sketch that way
i have a table oh i see see you don't
you don't do like an ipad uh script
where you can see it you don't no not
for that well yeah you wanna you you
wanna deforest the entire world for your
yes i am ruining the environment one
printing job at a time so uh not only
does gabe love uh uh kitchen equipment
in the soda stream he loves office
equipment too apparently yeah know
people wants to uh you know or canon or
you know
uh
office depot or you know whatever you
guys want to sponsor the show
hit me up i'm a big fan big fan you know
big fan big fan of inkjet huh yeah yeah
yeah well inkjet is a uh i think
yeah yeah laserjet is the i think the
copyrighted term or name for hp i don't
do oh is it oh you don't you're just
saying
it's not actually like lasers burning
into paper it's just too good for hp
i'll admit i have i have a uh copy
scanner fax machine
it's effective
but i've had it i've had it for a long
time and when it breaks i probably will
not buy a new one i probably well looky
looky here right
tony admits that he also killed it it
doesn't it doesn't even it's not even
hooked up i don't even think it's
plugged in it's like
just in case just in case you got to
make it i think you're going to have to
i don't know sounds like a big
conspiracy around the city
all right let's watch the rest of this
[ __ ] video yes
none of it's true i drive a pickup truck
and watch football so i'm definitely not
a good leftist right i love that i love
that i love it
i'm sure there's many moments where he
he
uh
will use that type of coping
like she'll prove a point and just dunk
on him and then she and then and then
instead of address the actual
point
he'll touch on something else and be
like i love that i love that right like
he's he's going to comment on the
trivial thing not the actual
me
right right the actual points yeah that
man so i have a feeling i haven't seen
it but i have a feeling that he probably
uses that tactic
uh because i've never really watched his
debates or so outside of the one where
he got owned by identifying
uh yeah dolphin fetus yeah a comedian's
name he does that game show what's the
comedian's name i forget yeah i yeah i i
i'll look it up yeah look at look at
that up see if you can find that clip
we'll play that clip um but but uh
charlie i i i know 100 got his ass just
handed to him uh for sure by rachel
bitkoffer there's no way that rachel
bitkoffer didn't get several punches in
and i have i have knowledge to know that
possibly possibly
there will be clips um that will be made
of of her doing that i'm sure so we will
we'll see we'll see how that turns out
okay let's let's move on and as gabe
looks up this uh charlie kirk then ben
glebe
ben glee do you have the clip on twitter
that i can find uh
oh oh hey daniel daniel dale's in the
news let's go to this clip real quick
and then we'll come back
[ __ ] dale we'll come back to um we'll
come back to this um
this uh daniel dale story i know gabe
loves daniel dale like they're they've
got like a bromance kind of thing we are
simpatico bro yeah you're he's in your
bio
yeah he is
uh he's like in your bio and [ __ ] yeah
fact yeah maybe fact checked by daniel
dale um here's the uh clip from bengali
um and this is on debate night now
they're not around the table so
apparently charlie has
done and there's more lighting here it's
really dark when he's got a woman on and
he's got a table to separate him when
he's got a woman on apparently i don't
know i i'm just assuming that has
something to do with it you know how am
i supposed to know
but here says charlie kirk schooled on
abortion in 15 seconds this is not very
long and if you've seen this this is
[ __ ] fantastic so watch him hand
charlie his ass on abortion do you truly
in your heart of hearts
truly believe that this is a human being
this without a doubt without a doubt yes
this is a dolphin fetus
as a human being this is a human the way
he sets it up
[Music]
is so good because he can't not like
dolphins right charlie can't help
himself
and you're like somebody's got human
babies in that aquarium
here's here's the best part about this
is not only did this happen to charlie
kirk
that [ __ ] [ __ ] published it
the only way that this exists
is because charlie kirk
published it yeah
not not because not because ben captured
this on camera this was done at charlie
kirk studio i believe it's in arizona
and captured this and then he released
it and let ben cut it up like this
that's
now i will tell you that that that's
part of their plan right like they
that's
well yeah that's that's how they do
they're like oh well you know we want to
make sure to get clips to make myself
look stupid so i trend but we have to we
can't not look away from these folks we
have to give them sunlight all right
let's go back to the daniel dale thing
and that's the other reason on related
to daniel dale that's the other reason
why when people get mad at me for you
know making
fake uh press releases from trump or
whatever they get mad like why are we
giving this guy more attention or if i'm
tweeting out or something
criticizing it's not even i'm not even
embedding a tweet i just take a
screenshot of a tweet and then i write
you know some sort of blurb about it and
people like stop giving stop driving
people to their profile stop giving them
attention it's like one
they're most likely an elected official
or some person that is like a verified
person on twitter that has a large
[ __ ] following
me over here i've got like 35 000
followers so don't tell me that i'm
gonna be the one that's obviously gonna
drive millions of people to go look at
this person and validate them on a
platform right they've already they've
already uh have a strong backing to
uh but it is very much that like i'm
going to point out and i'm going to
bring attention in and shed light on
something
and if we ignore it
then
it happens in the background and when it
finally does take over and it goes
[ __ ] south
uh and goes poorly then you're like well
i never saw it coming and it's like well
if you paid attention and actually
discussed it
you know just because you bring it up
doesn't mean you're giving them positive
reinforcement right
you're you're you're critiquing
criticizing giving feedback on a
situation
so don't act like any attention is
always a positive attention that goes to
the person you know so it's like when i
hear that from people i'm just like yeah
you do your thing you do i'll do mine if
you don't want to care for the stuff i'm
sharing then you can easily unfollow
block me whatever but like don't
don't just comment and be like stop
giving them attention it's like you're
drawing actually more engagement to this
book right
to the book right right commenting and
then and then retweeting and quote
tweeting and then and then getting in a
fight with someone down below it's
really is ridiculous um here here is uh
the uh the clip that daniel dale had a
problem with right so my just touch what
happened was you guys know we're
affiliated with midas touch now they're
our distribution partner we're in
association with midas touch thank you
to the mizellas brothers over at minus
touch for doing that
but uh yesterday
yesterday
they released a video of marjorie taylor
green looking at her cell phone while
everyone was clapping right
daniel dale i think it was newsweek
first fact check them what didn't
newsweek someone yeah
it was newsweek fact system and she goes
reported for misinformation yeah and
then i tweeted uh underneath that i
tagged you and daniel dale and i asked
for daniel dale's second opinion i don't
know if that's what triggered it
i i it is that's what that's what that's
what we're going with because they also
people were calling it out and they're
like oh this is misinformation and then
i know that they were looking for the
there was another cut of this video or
rather another cut of the feed from news
networks that actually did show her
clapping and it was like
you know very much well reminiscent of a
golf club here's here's that clip let's
watch this clip
zoomed in yep
um
nope
it was like it's like one two three four
cross hands i mean
here's the deal here's the deal
you see every single person even the
people who um love putin
uh and hate democracy in our country who
wanted to overthrow the democracy in our
country stood up and clapped right for
zielinski here but [ __ ] [ __ ] hooflet
green
zoom in first she's and looking around
looking around maybe uh
i might be pressured into it uh do i
want to look like a human being or just
uh evil person wearing human flesh i'll
go with the human flesh like the
distance you know let's you know daniel
i mean i responded to his tweet and i
was like i'm daniel dale and i
and i and i and i counted a number of
air compressions between my hands you
know or between margie taylor green's
hands like one
this is what you feel is so important
you have to fact check right and two
uh
she didn't give applause like she barely
clapped you know right well here's the
thing like if you're gonna fact check
why don't you go to her statement right
exactly and fact check like
mine is just pointing out that that she
was uh uninterested in what zielinski
was talking about was the news at that
moment
and then she gave her statement later on
and daniel dale shouldn't be fact
checking rather midas touch or whoever
pointed out in the moment she was
uninterested in democracy in that moment
and shows how she was uninterested in
democracy in that moment that she stands
with putin and then she proved it she
proved it you want to fact check daniel
nail you want to fact check there is
your fact check you see that minus touch
is calling her out for not standing up
for democracy not being interested in
the democracy wanting to placate to
putin and then she gives a statement
which is riddle the [ __ ] lies riddled
right with [ __ ] lies
and instead of giving a big huge thread
this morning on about how you know these
are all the lies that marjorie taylor
green told it's possible she did clap
she may have whatever
these are the actual lies
super pac might as touch spread this
viral tweet you know and it actually was
misinformed it's like
daniel let's focus on the important
stuff here right
her clapping is only a that was like
obviously before she did the response
but her clapping was obviously an
indicator to be like what her enthusiasm
level was about zielinski talking and
you're like okay yeah you know uh maybe
she wasn't really feeling or maybe
someone's going on and then she makes a
[ __ ] speech or like a response video
that again no one asked for except
herself who thought it was an important
thing to say so she doubled down on this
idea of like no one should be killed but
russia maybe they're not so bad after
like it's very much the tucker cross i'm
like i'm just asking questions i'm just
here to support the person who you know
like it it comes down to these people
will
will support russia and fight against
ukraine in whatever way possible and
they don't care if it looks bad
because
they're just going to say it's
misinformation or they're going to claim
it's fake news or they're going to say i
didn't really say that when there's four
[ __ ] 4k video of them actually saying
a statement out loud so
these these people are are a stain
on our democracy and
you know obviously fighting for fascism
where they will they'll deny any story
that makes it look like they're the bad
person
right well this is this video here on
the screen is the one that they released
where she's looking at her cell phone
here
at one moment where there's a standing
ovation because i believe there was many
moments of standing ovations the one the
one is where she almost decided to
collapse she did not clap i mean she was
kind of clapping but it was not an
applause so uh daniel if you're out
there i will challenge you to come on
the show and not only that um i don't i
don't know if brett is available but uh
brett my zealous i would invite both of
them on the show maybe maybe gabe you
could be the referee yeah um and and
then they could hash out what a paw what
applause actually is right and then i
mean
and then and then and then uh daniel and
brett can actually argue the facts of uh
and the the untruths and misinformation
that that piece of [ __ ] spread in her
statement about zielinski uh biden and
the deep state so uh daniel you're
welcome on the show anytime my man uh
you you know that well so come on daniel
i wish i wish we had his email i i can't
go dm him so yeah um but you know i wish
i had his email if anyone's got daniel's
email or knows daniel you might send it
to us we'll try to get in touch with him
um
i i do want to show
did you see this [ __ ] video which one
just won this game on plano yeah you
sent me that last night and i was like
did you see this guy what the hell is
this i don't even know it's got six
million views right now it looks like
spaghetti i don't know let's watch let's
watch like two seconds
spitting on the mic it's anti-vaxx
hates all of them blacks putin is a bad
racist okay i can't i can't handle it
the the audio he he's he doesn't know
what the microphone like what kind of my
piece is yeah it's he doesn't know it's
a condenser mic so you don't have to
like my mic i got it the i i've got it
turned all the way down because i'm
really loud so that way i can get close
to it and get the audio correct but he
he he doesn't understand that mike um so
it's really bad audio but
it's not only that he really puts on a
performance i mean this is like two
minutes and 20 seconds i made it through
like 40 seconds and i'm like oh my god
this guy is nuts i couldn't tell you
what he's saying i don't know who
it's i actually said
is this the new normal
someone someone unplugged the timeline
at home office and plug that [ __ ] back
in we need a reset um there's news in
the um the oath keepers you guys know we
try to follow stuart rhodes the founder
of the oath keepers here on the podcast
uh scott uh reports uh mcfarland
reports here jury trial
in the oath keepers u.s capital siege
seditious conspiracy cases set to begin
9 30 a.m on july 11th i would not put
that in your calendars by the way um you
can put it in uh tentatively it will be
changed trust me uh stuart rhodes the
oath keeper founder is in pre-trial
detention this will be changed trust me
trust me trust me this is not going to
be
the actual trial date
there will be more conspiracy charges
there will be superseding indictments
which will bring more evidence will
bring more discovery for their attorneys
and their attorneys will ask for more
time and the judge will hand it to them
uh because and in in the world of you
know
justice
in the world of justice uh we're
supposed to be given that adam
parkamento um uh
tweeted this video have you seen this
video of herschel walker
yeah about the herschel
this one here
the one that talks paige
no no i haven't seen this one warning
viewer discretion is advised which is
right up our alley by him or his no no
no no this is against him
um i'm trying to really christian
walker's dad ain't looking good yeah
well you know i know you christian
walker is your your uh your
fake satire roommate who's my real
roommate dude or he is your real
roommate
until daniel dale fact checks me
daniel if you're out there daniel if
you're out there we want a second
opinion on if christian walker is
actually i'll invite him to mtv cribs
and i'll show him exactly where
christian sleeps you know oh yeah that's
good that's good that way you can
daniel can do his job and fact check
[ __ ] that doesn't really matter right um
but you've done a lot of videos about
christian walker you did one just this
last week where he's losing his mind in
a car oh yeah it's very violently
against uh what was it was his is
starbucks coffee is going up it was the
prices of starbucks were going up and he
blamed biden and it was in addition to
another he had a whole rant about gas
prices which i will probably do a video
about but he did a whole rant about gas
prices and was then trying to conflate
the two of gas and starbucks and say how
it's all biden's fault
when one
the president of the united states does
not have a lever at his desk where he's
[ __ ] controlling the gas prices of
every country in the world or the
starbucks prices or the starbucks prices
or it does not have a coffee button
either he does not he does not uh have
control of the private gasoline
companies oil companies that that uh
charge up for gas and he does not also
have control of starbucks the private
coffee company now if people want the
president to have control then that
would imply that you also want socialism
which you say you're against so pick a
[ __ ] lane which one is it okay
but the point i was trying to make about
and i i appreciate your rant everyone
loves the gay brand here maybe we should
cut that gay brand out and put it on
social media because everyone loves the
gay brands here
but the point i was trying to make gabe
was that
christian walker kind of has this
tendency to have a violent outburst oh
yeah like like
really weird like like [ __ ] like
that's the type of response it's like
and it's almost like he's driving
through a starbucks and he's losing his
mind and then the window opens he's and
he changes he switches no he does the in
the vid because it always and i don't
you know obviously there's probably it's
intended to be that way but like nothing
and then he'd be like hi like that's the
no joke that is the [ __ ] that he has uh
in the video i'll find the other one
that i'll send it to you okay
i want to thank kathy here for the super
sticker thank you kathy for the super
sticker guys remember we have the super
chat now so if you want to help the
podcast out you can either do that
through super chat or super sticker
thank you thank you kathy for your
support and thank everyone for your
support i want to go back to this this
video here and the reason why i wanted
to bring up the christian walker where
he loses his mind
is because i think he learned it
somewhere i think you learned it
somewhere you might be able to see that
in this video possibly
warning viewer discretion is advised
by the way this is the tony michaels
podcast so um i wish every video that we
did like had that like maybe we should
be like just do that yeah welcome to the
tony michaels podcast viewer description
that is advised i think we should i
think we should let's play yeah what
yeah what would you say no i was gonna
say yeah i just agree yeah yeah but
let's let's let's make something like
that let's definitely do something like
that and make it uh i don't know i make
it uh uh something funny yeah yeah
are you thinking about voting for
herschel walker no the football legend
wait it sounds like a pharmaceutical
commercial let us share some things with
you
do you have erectiles
accused of quote physically abusive and
extremely threatening behavior that she
desperately sought a protective order
after walker threatened to kill her
did you know herschel once held a razor
to her throat and his ex-wife said he
choked her
and quote he held the gun to my temple
and said he was going to blow my brains
out or that herschel's mistress told
police that walker threatened to quote
blow her head off did you know about the
cheerleader who accused herschel of
threatening and stalking her following
her to her home
or that during one domestic violence
call herschel walker threatened a quote
shootout with police he threatened to
kill women he threatened to kill cops
after the violence the abuse the
stalking the death threats herschel
walker still has not been forthright
with the people of georgia not about his
violent behavior or the threats he has
made against he doesn't really live
there
right he lives in texas i think right
you wonder how many more women are out
there
and what stories might they tell
now ask yourself are you still thinking
about voting for herschel walker no it
wasn't there was gary black versus
warnock would be very intriguing in the
state oh if i were warnock you want to
face her walker you want it to be
herschel walker because in that in
either right you warnock black the race
is about warnock the incumbent warnock
walker the race is about walker and you
and i both know an incumbent would love
it not to be a referendum on them
and i don't know if this signal was i
i'm not sure what the end was what do
you think the end was about there
uh i don't know trying to basically just
trying to comment on who would be a a
politically and easier uh
tar or candidate to go against does
georgia have open primaries you know
what i mean by this uh yeah i think some
here's here's where i'm going with this
because claire mccaskill you remember um
it was several years ago when graham
claire mccaskill ran against a guy
called todd aiken he was the guy who
said oh if it's a legitimate rape the
the female body has a whole way of
shutting that thing down right
legitimate rape um he's a legitimate
rape guy and basically what claire
mccaskill did was say hey everyone go
vote for todd aiken because i can he's
an actual republican and she beat todd
aiken because todd aiken is gross and he
actually he didn't make those uh
legitimate rape comments until after he
won primary yeah it's called mccaskill
yeah yeah
there are one two three four five six
seven eight candidates right uh sorry is
it seven candidates running but is it is
it an open primary meaning meaning can a
democrat pull a republican ticket and
vote for the person that they want to
run against warnock do you follow me on
that
that's what happens in an open primary
uh brent thank you for the uh for the
super chat there
really appreciate it uh brent actually
might know this uh because he's rooming
but i'll tell you in open primary what
happens is
and and this is what happened in
missouri because missouri has open
primaries where you can actually go and
you you don't have to have a party
affiliation during a primary you can
actually pull whatever ticket you want
so if you want as a democrat to pull a
republican ticket and make sure that you
get the republican that you want on that
ticket to run against the democratic
candidate you can do that right yeah
so i don't know if that's the case in
georgia but i think maybe that's what
chuck todd was saying you know check
todd's kind of an idiot so who knows
really what he's saying most of the time
but but maybe that's what he the signal
that they're trying to project there at
the end of the ad like hey
go vote for walker
go vote for walker he's gonna get his
ass handed to him because it said to be
continued like this is just this this is
just the tip of the iceberg right on
herschel walker let's go to that you
sent me this link
um maybe we'll see
if his offspring learned anything from
him here
[Music]
um see if this is uh
uh this is is this the starbucks one
yeah yeah this is yeah the starbucks
believe me i have so many of these
videos where he goes crazy about
something where does he post these he's
in the starbucks drive-through he's
literally no i mean i mean like like
what's social media playing on instagram
facebook on instagram yeah yeah cause
he's he's not on is he on twitter
uh he is but he blocked me oh okay but
but he's he got banned from tick tock i
think it's the one yeah he got banned
from tick-tock twice and then he was
just started a new account recently oh
okay so you know tick-tock you know
banned really
make a new account then you're fine
right right okay let's let's uh let's
open this up here let's see
what he has to say about his starbucks
and joe biden with the coffee button on
his desk raising the coffee prices i can
barely afford to get my starbucks in the
morning
okay so this is a guy who's sitting in a
land rover right because that's what
this is a range rover whatever the [ __ ]
it is right
and i i can't tell if
because that's what he drives right
there's like a ranger i mean he's your
[ __ ] roommate you would yeah yeah
yeah it's a it's a it's a it's a i think
it's land rover is the official title
but yeah now he goes he goes to uh a
very fancy college right he goes to ucla
okay
60 70 000 right he lives he lives in a
you know a not so cheap part of town
right and yeah and yeah
that side of town i mean he is your
roommate so you would yeah yeah it's the
rent is not cheap right but he doesn't
pay for it his dad does well right right
well his dad is a former
um nfl player so this guy this game and
xfl uh hello oh well you know
trump before yeah is that how is that
how it was it wasn't xfl it was the uh
the uh
it was the yeah yeah yeah yeah trump was
that
whatever the hell usfl usfl that's what
it is yeah goddamn get your football
right before he uh before he you know
yeah uh shocked
it taken
trump bought a team with the usfl and it
tanked and
herschel walker was on that team right
everything trump touches turns to liquid
[ __ ] so here here is here is a rich boy
here um yelling and screaming about how
he can't afford his coffee and it's joe
biden's fault and to bring america back
i'm not understanding quite what this is
but
anyway yeah it's just one of those
things where christian walker has some
rant that is completely hypocritical and
contradicts some former point that he's
had he just screams into the camera and
his phone and tries to sound you know
somewhat intelligent about how
it's joe biden's fault or the democrats
or the courses well maybe under biden's
fault he's trending 100 is trending it
might be hunter binding's laptop's vault
gabe it's probably hundred bucks laptops
that that is who is racing that is who
is raising the prices in this country
his hunter biden's laptop is responsible
for all of this even though i will say
you know who's a better fundraiser than
margie taylor green hunter by the way
that is true yeah that is true like a
really good like they even sanctioned
hunter biden's laptop from russia yeah i
mean they're like don't don't get don't
allow this person to take any more money
we only speak facts here and we know
it's hillary clinton's emails and the
laptop that they wanted to sanction from
russia uh here's the report a new york
times article details the department of
justice inquiry into hunter biden's
business dealings including emails
emails gave emails between him and his
associates can you imagine can you
imagine someone emailing their
associates obtained by the publication
from a cache of files that appears to
have come
from a laptop abandoned by mr biden in a
delaware repair shop
what in the [ __ ] are we really gonna do
this more of this [ __ ] yeah we are we
i can't wait to write more hunter bite
and laptop uh uh tweets today i'm i'm
i'm all i'm already thinking about
hunter biden laptop uh tweets how
they're relevant uh to the world of
where putin is trying to tear down
democracy and the new york times wasn't
playing right in their hands uh wasn't
the repair shop guy he was on some fox
news show the other night well of course
he was on fire and it was like oh no if
you're like
if you look at this as um
as who's the hero who's the villain you
know you go up and you're like oh this
the repair shop guy you know the fox is
like the repair shop guy is standing up
against the villain that is hunter biden
in his laptop right right well i mean he
is a villain he is a villain i have
actually a good
laptop tweet this from a while back let
me see if i can find it here it's really
is the one where uh tucker carlson
asked for
uh
hunter biden to write a letter of
recommendation to georgetown for his son
buckley
uh there is that but i don't think that
is the one um and there's been several
where hunter biden's laptop has it's
breaking news that they he is that the
laptop is releasing statements but there
is one that i want to find here
um
i really i really want to find this one
if i can find it here i'm searching um i
had um there's a lot of breaking news
where hunter biden's laptop is holding
press conferences their hunter binds
laptop
is releasing statements oh here it is i
believe this one's it
yes i think this is
oh here we go 100 laptop right now
dude is that it is that it oh wait it's
probably because we're talking about it
i this is back on september 22nd 2021 i
said imagine how filthy the laptop must
feel when hunter biden turns it on
i'm giving it myself some love i'm going
to i'm going to do it i'm going to wear
it i was going to say you just copy the
copy the text and just post i am i i do
that a lot with tweets with the good
ones i mean if you're like it's good
repost it yeah well might as well might
as well um let's see here uh here's
another one i tweeted on february 17th
would you rather be hunter binding's
laptop or the trump organization so
um we're we really we really are
probably going to have to jump today
with that i appreciate you guys hanging
around remember go back re-watch the
interview with anthony scaramucci it's
fantastic uh he talks about the nfts he
talks he rails on ted cruz donald trump
yeah it's fantastic stuff it's fantastic
stuff remember tomorrow we'll have
bonehead we'll get the bonehead of the
week pull out today so you guys can vote
there's plenty of boneheads today to
vote for so we'll get that out today so
you guys can see it
and we'll do the bonehead of the week
tomorrow in the second hour don't forget
that and until tomorrow
noon eastern 11 central right here on
youtube twitter twitch surf's up
[ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking